[Musik]
wir leben im zeitalter der
globalisierung die ganze welt ist
vernetzt und treibt untereinander
handeln für den austausch von waren und
dienstleistungen braucht es allerdings
regeln zum beispiel kann eine regierung
zölle dafür verlangen dass güter in
irland eingeführt werden dürfen
sie bestimmt auf die standards denn man
sie verkaufen darf ein land kann sich
mit seinen handelspartnern auf
gemeinsame regeln einigen
sie schließen dann handelsverträge ab
oft einigen sich die länder darauf
hindernisse für den warenaustausch zu
verringern
sie wollen also mehr freihandel im
gegensatz dazu steht der protektionismus
protektionistische handelspolitik
erschwert und beschränkt das importieren
von gütern in der realität bewegt sich
die außenhandelspolitik eines landes
meist zwischen diesen polen für beide
vorgehensweisen gibt es nämlich gute
gründe
der freieren handel ermöglichen will
schafft zelle ab und vereinheitlicht
standards mit seinen handelspartnern
das sorgt für mehr warenvielfalt und
konkurrenz auf dem heimischen markt
davon erhoffen sich die handelspartner
niedrigere preise und einen zuwachs an
wohlstand zu protektionistischen
maßnahmen greift eine regierung wenn sie
teile ihrer wirtschaft vor ausländischer
konkurrenz schützen möchte zum beispiel
vor preisdumping
sie erhebt dann einfuhrzölle oder
beschränkt den import bestimmter waren
auch die subventionen vom eigenen
branchen ist eine protektionistische
maßnahme die meisten länder greifen
sowohl auf protektionistische also
freihandels fördernde maßnahmen zurück
die eu zum beispiel subventioniert ihre
landwirtschaft mit vielen milliarden
euro ist aber gleichzeitig die
zweitgrößte freihandelszone der welt was
meint ihr
braucht die welt mehr freihandel mehr
protektionismus oder liegt die wahrheit
in der mitte
schreibt uns doch in die kommentare